so you've mentioned the idea of a press
release the research and development
Amazon Alexa and I was on General you
kind of think of what the future product
will look like and you kind of make it
happen you work backwards
so can you draft for me you probably
have one paquimé makeup on for 10 20 30
40 years out that you see the Alexa team
putting out just in broad strokes
something that you dream about I think
let's start with the five years first
okay so and I'll get to the Fortius
through in broad strokes let's start
with I think the five years where I mean
I think of in these spaces it's hard
especially for you and thick of things
to think beyond the five years space
because a lot of things change right I
mean if you ask me five years back will
Alexa will be here I would have I think
it has surpassed my imagination of that
time right so I think then from the next
five years perspective from a AI
perspective what we're gonna see is that
notion which you said goal-oriented
dialogues and open domain like Alec
surprised I think that bridge is gonna
get closed they won't be different and
I'll give you why that's the case
you mentioned shopping how do you shop
do you shop in in one shot sure you're
double A batteries paper towels yes how
much how long does it take for you to
buy a camera you do ton of research yeah
then you make a decision so is there is
that a goal Arian to della dialogue when
I like somebody says Alexa find me a
camera is it simply in cues ative ness
right so even in this something that you
think of it as shopping which you've
said you yourself use a lot off if you
go beyond where it's reorders or items
where you sort of not brand conscious
and so forth that was just in shock just
to comment quickly I've never bought in
you think there Alexa there haven't
bought before on Amazon
a desktop after I clicked in a bunch you
read a much reviews that kind of stuff
that's repurchase so now you think in
even for something that you felt like is
is a finite goal I think the space is
huge because even products the
attributes are many like and you want to
look at reviews some on Amazon some
outside some you want to look at what
Zenit is saying or another consumer
forum is saying about even a product for
instance right so that's just - that's
just shopping where you could you could
argue the ultimate goal is sort of known
and we haven't talked about Alexa what's
the weather in Cape Cod this weekend
right so why am I asking that weather
question right so I think I think of it
as how do you complete goals with
minimum steps for our customers right
and when you think of it that way the
distinction between goal oriented and
conversations for open domain say goes
away I may want to know what happened in
the presidential debate right and is it
I'm seeking just information on I'm
looking at who's winning winning the
debates right so these are all quite
hard problems so even the five-year
horizon problem I'm like I sure hope
will solve these a new year you're
optimistic that's a hard problem which
part the reasoning you know enough to be
able to help explore complex goals that
are beyond something simplistic that
feels like it could be well five years
is a nice it's a nice bar form right I
think you will
it's a like nice ambition and do we have
press releases for that absolutely can I
tell you what specifically the roadmap
will be no right and what and will be
solve all of it in the five-year space
now this is we will work on this forever
actually if we this is the hardest of
the eye problems and I don't see if that
being solved even in a 40 year horizon
because even if you limit to the human
intelligence we know we are quite far
from that in fact every aspects of our
sensing to do neural processing to how
brain
stores information and how it processes
it we don't yet know how to represent
knowledge right so we are instill in
those are early stages so I wanted to
start that's why at the five-year yeah
because the five-year success would look
like that
and solving these complex goals and the
forty year would be where it's just
natural to talk to these in terms of
more of these complex goals right now
we've already come to the point where
these transactions you mentioned of
asking for weather or reordering
something or listening to your favorite
tune it's natural for you to ask your
like sites it's now unnatural to pick up
your phone right and that I think is the
first five-year transformation the next
five your transformation would be okay I
can plan my weekend with Alexa or I can
plan my next meal with Alexa or my next
night out with seamless effort
you